Speaker 1: So radical Republican or maybe
confused Republican Senator Lindsey Graham,
Lindsey Graham strikes me more as confused
than radical, I guess, although every once
in a while he will say something pretty radical.
He suggested assassinating Vladimir Putin,
and then all hell broke loose, and by the
next day there, there was no more talk of
assassination.
Instead, he was talking about arresting Vladimir
Putin, a much more sober and modest suggestion.
But I have to tell you what Lindsey Graham
said is not dissimilar to what is going on
in many intelligence agencies back rooms.
It's just you can't publicly say it.
I'm going to explain what I mean.
So let's get to the first clip.
This is Lindsey Graham in the evening.
I think this was Thursday night where he said,
We need a plot.
We need someone in there who's going to kill
Putin the way there was a plot to kill Hitler.
Speaker 2: How does this in somebody in Russia
has to step up to the plate?
Is there Brutus in Russia?
Is there a more successful Colonel Stop Berg
and the Russian military?
The only way this ends, my friend, is for
somebody in Russia to take this guy out.
You would be doing your country a great service
and the world a great service right now.
Speaker 1: That's that's pretty full on for
for a senator in the United States to say
the best path is assassinating Putin.
OK, so what is he talking about?
Well, he's talking about Stauffenberg, but
thoughtful name would be Klaus Philip, Maria
Justinian Schenk, Graf von Stauffenberg.
This was a German army officer who I guess
was executed a failed attempt in July of 1944
to assassinate Adolf Hitler at the so-called
Wolf's Lair.
So Lindsay is saying, we need something similar
and we need someone from inside Russia to
take out Vladimir Putin.
So this was completely irresponsible to say.
And obviously, it's being considered.
I mean, we let's not let's not play dumb here,
guys.
There is no doubt that every serious intelligence
agency and I'm not defending them from doing
it.
I'm just telling you that it's obviously going
on.
Every serious intelligence agency is giving
all options to their leaders, and one option
is, could we?
And if so, what would it take?
To assassinate Vladimir Putin or similarly,
I mean, the idea that Lindsey's talking about
is someone from inside Russia.
Any serious intelligence agency that has moles,
double agents, whatever within Russia would
be saying, Do we have anyone inside of Russia
close enough to Putin that they could potentially
assassinate Putin?
I'm not saying anyone is planning to do it.
I'm not saying that it should be done.
I'm saying when you are in a position of providing
options to leadership, you provide every option.
And almost always in situations like this,
one of the options is could we kill someone?
And could we do it with enough plausible deniability
that it can never be traced back to us?
However, it's not something a senator should
say.
It's very stupid.
It's extraordinarily dumb for Lindsey Graham
to say it, but to just write it off and pretend
these conversations are being had would be
extraordinarily naive.
Now, by the next day, Lindsey had completely
backed off.
Obviously, someone got to him and they were
like that.
You can't say that, you can't say that.
And Lindsey instead said, Well, we should
really be looking at arresting Putin.
Speaker 2: Mr. Ambassador, you're supporting
a war criminal and Putin.
Your country is engaged in war crimes in front
of the entire world.
You're bombing innocent civilians using banned
munitions.
You have a record your country does dropping
barrel bombs on people in Syria.
You've destroyed checks nearby a massive war
crimes.
You're committing war crimes in the Ukraine.
You need to apologize to the world for how
Putin has stolen your country blind, how they're
dismembering a neighboring democracy called
the Ukraine, how they're killing innocent
men women.
Speaker 1: Other than continuing to say the
Ukraine, Lindsey is basically right about
his allegations as to what's going
Speaker 2: on and children.
Indiscriminate use of force and violation
of the Geneva Convention.
You, my friend, are the one who needs to apologize.
And when it comes to Putin, he needs to go
to jail.
Speaker 1: OK, so toning it down very much
from the assassination talk to go to jail.
You could liken this to the previous night.
Lindsey was drunk texting, and then the next
day he sent an email to smooth things that
smooth things over.
OK?
And that's an analogy I'm not saying.
Literally, he was drunk texting the night
before.
So he's essentially right.
He was very wrong to talk about the assassination,
but let's let's be adults here.
Obviously, countries the world over are saying,
would we be able to pull off an assassination
and what would be the risks and the rewards
and the implications?
And as I said earlier, three assassination
attempts against Zelensky.
I don't believe that if you kill Zelensky,
you really change anything about Ukrainian
resistance.
In fact, I think you might bolster it because
they would be so invigorated by what would
be the insane killing of their president.
I do think, on the other hand, that if you
kill Putin, you do in a sense decapitate the
Russian movement, the Russian invasion, because
so many people in Russia clearly don't even
want to be doing it.
So that's what's going on.
And Lindsey said the wrong thing.
Quite frankly,